Donc on va faire de la méditation debout.
Donc vous pouvez vous mettre debout.
So just make sure that you are balanced.
Assurez-vous d'avoir une posture avec quelque chose d'équilibré.
Donc, relevez-vous, redressez-vous le long de la colonne vertébrale jusqu'au sommet de la tête.
Et passez un moment de relaxation, d'abord le bras,
Et puis, passez un petit moment à simplement vous détendre.
Et pour commencer, avant tout, les sourcils et le front.
Les joues et la mâchoire.
Si il y a de la tension là, juste waggle-la un peu.
Et s'il y a de la tension là, vous les remuez juste un peu, votre bon mâchoire.
Donc, les lèvres sont jointes et les dents séparées.
Les épaules.
Donnez-leur une bonne secousse, il y a la moindre tension.
Les mains sont jointes devant ou de chaque côté du corps, cela n'a pas d'importance, privilégiez une position qui vous soit confortable.
Just acknowledge the posture, the energy running up the spine, everything else, relax.
Donc, prenez conscience de votre posture avec une colonne vertébrale énergisée, pleine d'énergie et tout le reste détendu.
Cet exercice dure environ 10 minutes ou plus.
Si c'est trop long, sieds-toi.
Tu peux le faire en se disant.
Donc cet exercice dure environ 10 minutes, un petit peu plus peut-être, si c'est 10 à 20 minutes.
Si c'est trop pour vous, vous vous asseyez.
Portez votre attention à la paume de vos pieds.
Qu'est-ce que vous pouvez ressentir à cet endroit-là ?
La plante de vos pieds.
Est-ce que vous pouvez isoler les sensations liées à la pression ?
Et puis, y a-t-il de la chaleur ou du froid ?
Et qu'en est-il des sensations subtiles qui vous renseignent au sujet de ce sur quoi vous êtes debout ?
La douceur, le moelleux du tapis.
Des zones du pied que vous ne pouvez pas ressentir.
Très neutre.
Et puis il y a peut-être des parties de votre pied que vous ne pouvez pas ressentir, qui sont très neutres.
Et reconnaissez comment l'ensemble des sensations changent perpétuellement alors que le corps se rééquilibre.
Le corps en train de se rééquilibrer.
Et prenez conscience du fait que ces sensations surviennent, que vous le décidiez ou non.
Et puis prenez votre temps maintenant, regardez ce que vous ressentez en remontant le corps et regardez ce que vous ressentez à la fois à l'extérieur et à l'intérieur.
Et ayez conscience des endroits qui donnent l'impression
d'être exempt de sensations ?
Et quand vous arrivez au niveau du ventre, est-ce que vous pouvez ressentir la respiration à cet endroit ?
Est-ce qu'il y a une tension là ?
Est-ce qu'il y a des tensions à cet endroit ?
Ne faites rien, ressentez simplement.
Est-ce qu'il y a des sensations de la respiration dans la zone de l'estomac ?
Des tensions ?
Et qu'en est-il de la poitrine ?
Est-ce que vous pouvez sentir la respiration à cet endroit ?
Respirez naturellement.
Des tensions.
Sentez le battement de votre cœur.
Les épaules restent détendues.
Les mâchoires.
Les lèvres jointes et les dents séparées.
Le front, les tempes et les sourcils.
Et scanne le cou, comme tu l'as fait avec les seins de tes pieds.
Qu'est-ce que tu peux ressentir là ?
Et puis, vous faites un petit scanner sur votre crâne, comme vous l'avez fait pour la paume de vos pieds.
Et qu'est-ce que vous pouvez ressentir à cet endroit-là?
Et là maintenant, sans ouvrir vos yeux, parce qu'on médite dans la tradition les yeux fermés, prenez conscience de ce qu'il y a à l'extérieur de vous, sans ouvrir les yeux.
Sans ouvrir les yeux.
Non, non, ouvrez les yeux, ne les bougez pas.
Ok, donc maintenant on ouvre les yeux, mais on ne les bouge pas.
Donc prenez conscience des couleurs et des formes autour de vous.
Est-ce qu'il y a des sons ?
Quelle est l'atmosphère de la pièce dans laquelle vous vous trouvez ?
Est-ce qu'il y a un certain sens de quelqu'un à côté de vous dans votre appartement, dans votre maison, des voisins ?
Et au même moment, en même temps,
Prenez conscience de l'intérieur.
Les sensations des pieds, de la respiration, à la fois l'intérieur et l'extérieur.
Ça, c'est la bulle de notre conscience.
C'est le monde que nous créons.
C'est notre univers.
Et nous sommes toujours à son centre.
Alors nous pouvons aussi bien nous détendre.
Se détendant dans le moment présent
pleinement éveillé.
Demeurons dans le moment présent pleinement éveillé.
Dans ce mode de simplement être, nous pouvons abandonner
toute idée de réaliser quelque chose, d'accomplir quelque chose, d'être quelqu'un.
Dans ce mode de simplement être, il n'y a aucun objectif.
Le but est juste d'être.
L'objectif, c'est simplement d'être.
Demeurant dans le moment présent, pleinement éveillé.
Dans ce mode, nous pouvons laisser tomber les pensées, les idées au sujet du futur.
Il n'y a aucun besoin de faire des plans, de planifier, nous n'allons nulle part.
On est tout le temps en train d'arriver.
Dans ce mode de simplement être, on est très passif.
On ne réagit pas, on ne répond pas à quoi que ce soit.
On est simplement en train de recevoir des informations.
et alors on n'a pas besoin d'être une personnalité de présenter quelqu'un on peut être anonyme abiding in the present moment
Achieving nothing, going nowhere, being nobody.
Demeurant dans le moment présent, n'accomplissant rien, n'étant personne, n'allant nulle part.
Dans ce mode, nous développons 5 des 7 facteurs qui conduisent à la libération.
Dans ce mode, nous développons cinq des sept facteurs qui conduisent à la libération.
Bien sûr, il y a la conscience, l'attention.
Une stabilité de l'attention, en plus de la conscience, la concentration.
Et l'effort requis pour pouvoir maintenir l'attention précise.
Et un arrière-fond de calme parce que nous n'essayons pas de réaliser, d'accomplir quelque chose.
Et une qualité d'équanimité.
C'est l'esprit ouvert, le cœur ouvert.
Ne venant pas d'une position fixe.
D'une pensée, d'une opinion.
Très ouvert, l'esprit très ouvert.
Ne venant pas de l'aversion ou de la peur.
De l'avidité des préférences.
Avec un cœur très ouvert.
Quand ces cinq facteurs sont établis, nous pouvons ajouter les deux autres facteurs.
Et quand ces cinq facteurs sont établis, on peut faire venir les deux autres facteurs.
Un sens de la curiosité au sujet des enseignements du Bouddha.
Et plus particulièrement, les trois caractéristiques de l'existence.
Comment est-ce que nous créons la souffrance pour nous-mêmes ?
L'impermanence et le non-soi.
Ce mode de simplement être est important dans la vie ordinaire.
Et aussi pendant cette retraite, jamais nous ne faisons quelque chose.
Et quand nous avons terminé quelque chose, juste nous nous arrêtons.
Et on peut regarder ce qu'a été notre réaction ou notre réponse.
suis-je irrité, suis-je en train de courir ?
suis-je dans un état de paix ?
et donc on attend simplement que les ressentis négatifs s'épuisent de même un peu
Et après, nous pouvons regarder l'intention qui suit.
Et si c'est une intention non bénéfique, nous attendons simplement que cette énergie se puisse toute seule.
Et si c'est une intention bénéfique, bien sûr, nous la renforçons.
Et maintenant, notre prochaine intention c'est de nous asseoir.
Et donc, prenez vraiment votre temps et prenez conscience de toutes les actions qui sont nécessaires pour se mettre en position assise.
Et regardez si vous pouvez trouver des petits mots de notation pour vous aider à garder votre attention sur ce que vous êtes en train de faire.
Pushing, pulling, lifting, dropping.
Intending to sit.
Intention de s'asseoir
donc simplement on se redresse le corps jusqu'au sommet de la tête et de nouveau placez votre attention sur la partie basse du corps en vous détendant du mieux que vous pouvez
Donc, après, maintenant, nous plaçons notre attention sur la respiration.
Dans cette tradition, on préfère placer l'attention sur la respiration dans le corps.
Mais si vous avez déjà une habitude bien établie de...
Et faire attention à la respiration au niveau des narines, c'est bon.
Et puis, posez votre attention avec douceur sur la sensation douce de la respiration, son processus.
Et alors que l'abdomen se soulève, nous pouvons dire « se soulève » et quand il s'abaisse, dire « s'abaisse ».
Donc ne dites pas cela avant
Avant la respiration, faites-le vraiment la petite note mentale en même temps que l'acte lui-même, sinon cela donnera une impression de contrôle de la respiration.
Donc, si l'esprit vagabonde, dès que vous vous en apercevez, reconnaissez et prenez conscience de l'état d'esprit qui conduit l'esprit à s'en aller, de ce qu'il y a derrière.
Planning, planning,
Par exemple, planifiez, planifiez, s'inquiétez, s'inquiétez.
Vous pouvez répéter, dans ce cas-là, vous vous apercevez, vous répétez le mot.
Et puis, ramenez votre attention sur la respiration.
Ressentez-vous un peu doux, dormant, restez en levant la cheville.
Si vous vous sentez endormi ou somnolent ou léthargique, vous passez votre temps à vous redresser la colonne vertébrale.
Vous pouvez aussi ouvrir les yeux et maintenir l'attention à l'intérieur.
Vous pouvez même vous mettre debout.
en laissant votre attention sur les sensations douces provoquées par la respiration, leur permettant de réduire au silence l'esprit, d'apporter le calme au cœur.
La tranquillité, l'immobilité au corps.
S'élever, s'abaisser.
L'esprit vagabonde, dès que vous vous en apercevez, reconnaissez et prenez conscience de l'énergie qui conduit l'esprit à vagabonder ainsi.
Qu'est-ce qu'il y a derrière cette pensée ?
Laissez tomber l'histoire.
On s'intéresse seulement à l'attitude, à l'humeur, à l'énergie de l'émotion.
Irritation, irritation.
Et on répète par des petits mots ce dont il s'agit, qu'on a remarqué par exemple, irritation, irritation.
Romance, romance.
Imagination romantique, imagination romantique.
Et puis ramener l'attention sur la respiration.
Vous vous sentez endormi, fatigué ?
Eh bien, redressez la colonne, ouvrez les yeux, levez-vous.
As we begin to feel more focused, see if you can draw closer to the breath.
Alors que nous commençons à être plus focalisés, regardez si vous pouvez vous approcher davantage de la respiration.
Est-ce qu'on est capable de voir le tout début de l'inspire et de rester à sa fin ?
voir le début de l'expire et rester jusqu'à sa toute fin.
Si vous sentez des tensions quand vous faites cela,
Remettez-vous à l'intérieur de vous-même et ayez l'impression de recevoir la respiration.
Alors que nous commençons à être plus concentrés, à avoir une attention plus stable, nous pouvons nous ouvrir à ce qui appelle notre attention, en dehors de la respiration.
Si c'est un son, notre attention va vers l'oeil.
un son, alors notre attention va sur les oreilles.
On ne s'intéresse pas à l'explication au sujet de ce qui cause ce son.
On s'intéresse au processus de l'écoute et de l'entendre.
et on peut répéter intérieurement entendre entendre c'est une sensation dans le corps provoquée par le corps comme par exemple une démangeaison l'envie de se gratter go to it feel it
allez dans la sensation ressentez-la faites-en une expérience intime et vous pouvez répéter intérieurement deux fois une description de ce qui se passe se gratter peut se gratter enfin démangeaison démangeaison pas se gratter justement
Mais si c'est vraiment terrible, vous pouvez vous gratter.
Et vous dites, se gratter, se gratter.
Et observer comment le cœur se calme.
Si c'est un ressenti dans le corps causé par une émotion
C'est un ressenti dans le corps provoqué par une émotion.
Alors, allez porter votre attention au ressenti de l'émotion.
Faites-en une expérience intime.
Anxieté.
Et vous pouvez répéter pareil deux fois ce qui se passe.
Anxiété, anxiété.
Joie, joie.
Et regardez si vous pouvez attendre jusqu'à ce que cela commence à disparaître.
Et s'il n'y a rien qui attire votre attention, alors vous retournez à la respiration.
Peut-être que vous ne retournerez pas une seule fois à la respiration pendant tout le reste de l'assise.
La respiration, c'est votre ancrage, votre point de départ.
C'est l'endroit où vous revenez toujours quand vous n'avez rien qui attire votre attention et également l'endroit où vous revenez quand vous êtes dans un état de confusion.
On commence avec la respiration.
S'élever, s'abaisser.
En devenant conscients de la manière dont nous réagissons à ce dont nous faisons l'expérience.
Quand quelque chose est agréable, nous sommes attirés vers lui, nous voulons le maintenir, nous voulons le faire grandir.
Quand quelque chose est agréable, nous sommes attirés par cette chose.
Nous voulons la préserver, la continuer et qu'elle croisse.
Et quand quelque chose est désagréable, on a tendance à le rejeter.
à essayer de trouver quelque chose pour nous en divertir, pour ne pas y penser et à vouloir que cela cesse.
Ce sont ces deux sortes de désirs, dit le Bouddha, qui causent notre souffrance.
Est-ce que c'est vrai ?
Tout ce dont nous faisons l'expérience survient et disparaît.
Les sensations arrivent et s'en vont.
Les émotions surviennent et disparaissent.
les pensées, les images traversent l'esprit en un éclair rien ne se répète chaque respiration est similaire mais pas la même rien ne demeure
Est-ce qu'il y a quelque chose sur lequel nous pouvons nous reposer, à laquelle nous pouvons nous fier ?
Quand nous pratiquons vipassana, nous nous mettons dans un poste d'observation.
De cette position, de cette position intérieure, nous pouvons voir, nous pouvons ressentir tout ce qui se passe dans cet organisme.
De cette position, nous pouvons voir, nous pouvons ressentir tout ce qui survient dans notre univers intérieur.
Les sensations, les émotions, les pensées sont toutes des objets.
Il y a une distance entre l'observer et l'observateur.
Il y a une distance entre l'observateur et l'observé, celui qui ressent et ce qui est ressenti.
Celui qui fait l'expérience et ce qui est expérimenté.
Vous pouvez faire cela plus clair à vous-même en mettant le mot
Et vous pouvez rendre cela clair pour vous-même en mettant les mots juste devant, grâce aux petits mots de notation mentale que Panté nous a proposés tout à l'heure.
Si il y a de l'inconfort dans les pieds, là-bas, c'est l'inconfort.
Et s'il y a de l'inconfort dans les genoux, c'est là, là-bas, dans les genoux qu'il y a de l'inconfort.
Et s'il y a une émotion, c'est là-bas, là, qu'il y a dans la poitrine, dans l'estomac, cette émotion.
Et les pensées, les images, surviennent là, devant vous.
Tout est un objet.
Est-ce que le perceiveur est le perceiveur ?
Est-ce que celui qui perçoit peut être ce qui est perçu ?
Nous sommes dans ce poste d'observation à l'intérieur de nous-mêmes.
Nous pouvons nous apercevoir que toute chose survient par elle-même.
Le corps nous offre des sensations, si nous les voulons.
Le cœur offre des émotions que nous le voulions ou non.
Et l'esprit cherche tout le temps à essayer de penser.
Rien n'est sous notre contrôle direct.
Comment cela peut-il être moi ?
Mettons de côté toutes les instructions.
Ayons confiance dans cette conscience intuitive qui comprend de par elle-même.
Nous n'avons pas besoin de penser à quelque chose de particulier.
Just watch, just feel, just experience intimately.
Simplement regarder, ressentir, faire l'expérience intime.
Whatever draws our attention within the field of awareness.
Ce qui apporte, ce qui retient notre attention dans le champ de conscience.
Ne faites rien, ne changez rien.
Quand nous arrivons à la fin d'une assise, c'est bon de réfléchir un peu.
Est-ce que nous avons été diligents pour nous ramener au moment présent ?
Peu importe le nombre de fois où mon esprit a vagabondé, je l'ai simplement ramené gentiment à la respiration au corps.
Si je pense que mon effort a été plutôt vraiment constant, alors il faut que je me félicite.
Si je pense que j'aurais pu être plus diligent, alors il faut que je m'encourage.
Ne sors pas de la self-criticism.
Ne sombrez pas dans la critique de vous-même.
Comment avez-vous géré les différents états physiques et mentaux ?
Êtes-vous habile, malhabile, dans la confusion ?
Choisissez l'un de ces états.
L'agitation, l'esprit qui pense, qui s'obsède ou une grosse émotion.
Ou alors une douleur physique.
Si vous pensez que vous avez été habile, alors félicitez-vous.
Et si vous pensez que vous auriez pu être plus habile, alors vous vous encouragez.
Si vous étiez dans la confusion, alors il vous faut demander à l'enseignant.
Laquelle de ces trois caractéristiques de l'existence était la plus prégnante pour vous ?
Le processus du désir ?
L'impermanence ?
Ou que tout est un objet, pas sous notre contrôle direct ?
Ou bien est-ce que c'était le fait que tout est un objet, pas sous notre contrôle direct ?